y
[Música]
el gobierno de eeuu impuso nuevas
sanciones contra el ministerio de
defensa de irán contra algunas entidades
e individuos que están relacionados con
el programa nuclear de ese país medidas
que entrarán en vigor a partir del día
de hoy asimismo también hay nuevas
sanciones contra nicolás maduró por
violar el embargo de armas que tiene la
república islámica de irán
hablamos con nuestra corresponsal en la
ciudad de nueva york
la bancada demócrata al pedido al
presidente de eeuu donald trump que
retrase el nombramiento del nuevo juez
de la corte suprema que reemplazará a
ruth báder ginsburg dada la cercanía a
la fecha de las elecciones
presidenciales el nombramiento generó
una puja entre demócratas y republicanos
y pensé a la pandemia del hobbit 19
colombia tuvo una jornada de paro
nacional convocada por diferentes
sectores sociales los manifestantes que
terminaron en disturbios rechazan las
masacres recientes la muerte de líderes
sociales y también los recientes hechos
de brutalidad policial tenemos un
reporte desde la ciudad de bogotá a la
capital colombiana
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora el gobierno de eeuu impuso
nuevas sanciones contra el ministerio de
defensa de irán así como a 27 entidades
e individuos que están relacionados con
el programa nuclear iraní también el
país norteamericano anunció sanciones
contra nicolás maduró por considerar que
violó el embargo de armas
internacionales que pesa sobre la
república islámica de irán
washington espera que estas sanciones
sean también respetadas y sobre todo
respaldadas por otros países aliados
como el reino unido francia y alemania-
este tema podría llegar a la asamblea
general de las naciones unidas que
comenzó de manera virtual será un
escenario de discusión entre los dos
países vamos a ampliar esta información
con mamá en sala desde la ciudad de
nueva york quien ha seguido la jornada
de hoy de esa asamblea de las naciones
unidas' muy buenas noches se mamen y
eeuu y las sanciones que ha impuesto a
irán y a nicolás maduró podría ser uno
de los temas fuertes de esta asamblea
dado el escenario que representa donde
los
prácticamente tienen la oportunidad de
tener un cara a cara entre sus
gobernantes representantes o delegados
estoy muy buenas noches santiago así es
además es que en medio mundo está
pendiente de sí cara a cara virtual
entre ambos mandatarios después de que
como decías de eeuu haya impuesto esas
sanciones a irán ya venezuela por violar
el embargo de armas impuesto a teherán
de momento este anuncio va a suponer un
momento de tensión de problema para
algunos países incluso para aliados
europeos como alemania como francia y
además también como reino unido que ya
han dejado claro que estas sanciones
pues carecen de efecto legal porque al
final eeuu que salió del acuerdo nuclear
en el 2018 y precisamente el secretario
general de las naciones unidas
antonio guterres se ha dicho que la onu
tampoco se decantará se decidirá hasta
que el consejo de seguridad no se decida
desde luego vamos a ver un
enfrentamiento en esta asamblea general
como decías un escenario mundial único
en el que ambos mandatarios podrán
defender sus posiciones y para eso no
vamos a tener que esperar mucho porque
mañana mismo es el turno de ambos por
tradición donald trump intervendrá justo
después del discurso del presidente
sileño yer bolsonaro y más hacia la
tarde será el turno del presidente iraní
hassan roban y mame injusto hoy
comenzaron estas rondas de
presentaciones a lo largo del día en
esta asamblea general de las naciones
unidas cuáles son los detalles de esta
jornada que estuvo básicamente enfocada
en el multilateralismo
sí pues esta jornada de santiago se ha
dedicado a celebrar el 75 aniversario de
las naciones unidas y sea que él sea
bueno que seas he podido conseguir una
firma por parte de los estados miembros
de una declaración de que se va a luchar
por fortalecer el multilateralismo justo
en un momento en el que el mundo se
encuentra más polarizado que nunca por
la pandemia en la que nos encontramos ha
sido muy interesante escuchar las
intervenciones del presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro quien ha
apuntado a que este es un momento para
defender la labor de la organización
mundial de la salud y no para atacarla
justo precisamente cuando el presidente
de eeuu donald trump continúa con esos
ataques directos a la gestión que ha
hecho de la pandemia este organismo
además también ha pedido al secretario
general de las naciones unidas antonio
guterres que envía una comisión técnica
para vigilar las próximas elecciones que
tendrán lugar el día 6 de diciembre
interesante también el discurso del
presidente chileno sebastián piñera
quien ha asegurado que es el momento de
modernizar este organismo la
organización
y las naciones unidas y ha dicho también
que es el momento de reformar el consejo
de seguridad de las naciones unidas
porque se ha quedado un poquito anclado
en el tiempo y porque ya no responde a
las necesidades y desafíos de los
tiempos actuales
amén muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de nueva york y
precisamente el secretario de estado de
eeuu smile pompeu se refería a estas
sanciones que hoy impuso washington al
gobierno iraní
hoy tomaré la primera acción bajo esta
nueva orden ejecutiva sancionando al
ministerio de defensa y logística de las
fuerzas armadas de irán y a la
organización de las industrias de
defensa de irán ya su director también
sancionaremos al anterior presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro durante casi
dos años los funcionarios corruptos de
teherán han trabajado con el régimen
ilegítimo de venezuela para burlar el
embargo de armas de la onu nuestras
acciones de hoy son una advertencia que
debería ser escuchada en todo el mundo
vamos a seguir en eeuu porque la muerte
de ruth báder ginsburg la jueza
progresista de la corte suprema- alcanzó
también la campaña presidencial de ese
país el mandatario de eeuu donald trump
ha prometido que designará un reemplazo
el próximo viernes o sábado mientras que
la oposición la bancada demócrata le
pide que no nombre a un sucesor dada la
cercanía que hay con la fecha de los
próximos comicios presidenciales que
están previstos para el 3 de noviembre
en caso de que trump nominará a otro
juez para esta corte está quedaría con
un fuerte sesgo conservador con temas
como el derecho al aborto que podría
quedar
y su revisión
en 2018 la nominación del conservador va
a venir como juez de la corte suprema
sacudió a eeuu la máxima instancia
judicial del país que tiene la última
palabra sobre los grandes temas de la
sociedad tales como el derecho al aborto
el porte de armas la inmigración de los
derechos de la población lgbt y se
inclinaba hacia una mayoría conservadora
de 5 a 4 antes de que el senado les dé
su aprobación los jueces de la corte
suprema son nominados por el presidente
de eeuu es un puesto vitalicio una
designación que puede impactar en la
política de la unión americana de manera
perdurable no es por tanto una sorpresa
que las nominaciones a la corte suprema
constituyan un gran desafío político
a designación de un nuevo juez por parte
de donald trump brindaría una
considerable ventaja a los conservadores
6 contra 3 es por eso que el trump cuyo
mandato presidencial está en juego
quiere actuar rápido antes de las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre algo a lo
que se oponen con fuerza los demócratas
yo byd en su adversario electoral le
pide el senado que no vote antes de los
comicios en 2016 año electoral el senado
se había negado a votar sobre un
candidato nombrado por el ex presidente
barack obama argumentando que no podría
tomar tal decisión en medio de una
contienda electoral cuatro años más
tarde el líder de los republicanos en el
senado parece no recordar ese episodio
mitch mcconnell y ha dejado saber que
organizaría una votación sidra nostrum
anuncia su elección
en otros temas colombia vivió una nueva
jornada de paro nacional en varias
ciudades del país que reunió a varios
sectores de la sociedad colombiana los
detalles los tiene desde bogotá luís
muñoz
colombia vive este 21 de septiembre una
caravana social por la vida y por la paz
organizada por el comité nacional de
paro que está formado por sindicatos y
también por movimientos sociales aquí en
la céntrica plaza bolívar de la capital
colombiana de bogotá era el lugar donde
tenían que confluir 13 marchas que
salían desde distintos puntos de la
ciudad
sin embargo cuando había concentradas
apenas unos pocos miles de personas ha
empezado los enfrentamientos entre la
policía y los manifestantes cuando un
pequeño grupo ha lanzado piedras a la
policía también ha habido otro grupo que
ha hecho una cadena humana para defender
a la policía de esas de esos
lanzamientos de piedras poco después en
los aldeanos de la plaza bolívar se han
producido la disipación de una de las
marchas que llegaba del sur cuando la
policía tirado también gases
lacrimógenos y bombas aturdidoras que
los manifestantes han respondido con
piedras esta convocatoria el 21 de
septiembre es en memoria de los 13
fallecidos del 9 y el 10 de septiembre
que murieron a manos de la policía por
fuego real después de que se quemasen
también 70 estaciones de policía además
de estos hechos también se están
protestando por la gestión del gobierno
de la pandemia desde el punto de vista
económico y social unas protestas que no
sólo se han reducido a vota sino que
en otras ciudades del país como medellín
cali y barranquilla
es todo por el momento quién france24
siga con nuestra programación feliz
noche
[Música]